who is the greatest
grappler ever you were very
astute in the way you asked that
question you didn't say the greatest
jujitsu player
of all time you specified grappler
what's the bigger
category jiu-jitsu is the bigger
category juju has four faces
there is ghee competition there is no
gear competition
there is mixed martial arts competition
and there is self-defense
so jiu-jitsu has four aspects
grappling typically refers only to the
nogi
aspect of jiu-jitsu so it's one out of
four possibilities
so who's the greatest jitsu practitioner
ever
and then who is the greatest grappler
ever i believe
that the greatest jiu jitsu player
certainly that i ever met and i believe
of all time i
i i don't want to sound arrogant on that
because really you can only go with your
own experiences and there are
some great athletes that other people
mention that i i just never met
so um but in my estimation the greatest
jiu jitsu player
is hodger gracie my reasoning for that
is out of the four
faces of jiu-jitsu he excelled
in three and in two of them in
particular
he was the best of his generation by a
landslide
in ghee grappling nogi grappling
hodger dominated his generation
to a degree that is
truly impressive what do you attribute
that dominance to by the way is there
something
if you were to analyze them fascinating
question i'll come back to it
uh in mixed martial arts he was at his
peak uh i believe ranked in the top ten
in the uh in the world of mixed martial
arts
uh he wasn't the best in mixed martial
arts the way he was in grappling but he
was damn good
and um he beat some significant people
so
he showed tremendous versatility ghee
nogi mixed martial arts
uh he's not really known in the world of
self-defense but there's no real
criteria by which you would become
dominant in self-defense so that's kind
of a
you can't really judge people by that
i'm believing i'm
i thought you got into a fight in the
street i'm sure he would do just fine
so i i had no concerns about that um
uh so i would say that if you look at
jujitsu for what i believe it is a
a sport with four faces i believe it's
uh you you have to go with hodger gracie
as the one who
went out and empirically proved his
ability to to go across those those
elements and
do extraordinarily well in all of them
he even made the um
the extraordinary step of coming out of
retirement and beating the best
of the generation that came after him
yes that's a truly difficult sounds
incredible yeah and a sport which
progresses very very rapidly that's a
truly impressive accomplishment
so i'd like to talk to you about gordon
hodger and uh george gsb
let's first talk about what do you think
is this very different
from my perspective maybe you can
correct me but very different
artists yes masters of their uh
pursuits so what makes hodger so good
hoja was probably the living embodiment
of someone who played a classical
jiu jitsu game based around the the
fundamental
four steps of jiu-jitsu and and
like if if you took someone who had
taken introduction lessons in jiu-jitsu
for
three months they would recognize
the outlines of hodges game
with many of the techniques they learned
in those first three months
hodger was the best example of the
dichotomy between
the fundamentals of jiu-jitsu but also a
kind of hidden sophistication
underneath those fundamentals
people always say oh you know hodges
game was so basic
no the outlines of hodges game were
basic
but the degree of sophistication and the
application was extraordinary
and his ability to refine
existing technology was truly impressive
i never saw anyone in his generation
that even came close to his
uh his ability both in competition and
uh
uh in the gym so for people who don't
know
hodge gracie basically used just like
you said a very
simple techniques on the surface
from the outsider's perspective that
most people learn when they start jiu
jitsu
like a passing guard in a very simple
way taking mount
and choking from mount uh also
when he's on his back this closed guard
and all the basic submissions from coast
guard armbar and
triangle and just that's it
and being able to dominate shut down
and submit so control and submit the
best people in the world
for many many years just like you said
including
coming out of retirement and beating the
best
perhaps by far the best of the next
generation
so that's that just kind of lays out the
story is there some lessons
about his systems
that you learn in developing your own
system
excellent question the the thing which
always impressed me the most about
uh hodger was
his relentless pursuit of uh
of position to submission everything was
done
with the belief that
no victory was worthwhile if it didn't
involve submitting his opponent
that's a mindset that i try very very
hard to imbue in my students
the easiest path to victory in jiu-jitsu
is the one which
takes the least risk so for example you
will see
many modern athletes focus on scoring
the first point or the fourth
first advantage and then doing the
minimum amount of work
to each out a victory once they've done
that they get a small tactical advantage
they realize they're ahead take no more
risks and just
do the minimum amount of work to get the
victory
hodges mindset was always to take
the riskier gambit of submission which
entails a lot more work
and in many cases a lot more skill
what i always liked about hodger is he
never tried to play
tactics it was always just go out there
and try to win by submission and
that more than anything that mindset of
looking for the most perfect victory
rather than the victory that takes the
least skill
and the least effort is probably the
thing i took from his career the most
and tried to work upon in my students
i always wonder what are the little
details he's doing
under there when he's in mount the
little adjustments
you know but perhaps that's like almost
indescribable
the the details of that control
you